Blue Beetle might just be the win that
the DC film franchise has been waiting
for here's what Twitter is saying about
the newest and bluest superhero film in
theaters Blue Beetle is the start of a
new beginning for Warner Brothers and a
slate of DC films as the superhero genre
continues to expand DC has been going
through an identity crisis following
recent Financial misfires Warner
Brothers announced that it would be
overhauling its entire DC Cinematic
Universe handing filmmaker James Gunn
and Veteran producer Peter Safran the
keys to the kingdom as a franchise's new
Architects since last year the duo has
been headlining DC Studios as co-ceos
their new gigs will see them rebooting
and streamlining the expansive superhero
series you're originally part of the old
batch of DC flicks Blue Beetle director
Angel Manuel Soto confirmed to Total
film magazine that the project would be
part of gun Slater films the director
said we are part of the universe we are
part of the world we are part of the
plans that they have been creating for
the future installments of the DCU and
it looks like Blue Beetle is kicking off
gun and saffron's new DCU with a bang as
the film was receiving positive
reactions from critics and fans the
reactions are Soto's superhero debut are
positive with many praising that DC
films diversity familial themes and
emotional Heights the rap writer Umberto
Gonzalez wrote on Twitter Blue Beetle is
here and Latinos finally have a
superhero of their own reflected on the
big screen the film is so incredibly
good so unique and delivers on all
fronts giving the superhero genre much
needed sosan the film's Tangerine Dream
inspired simple eight score also rocks
what makes Blue Beetle stand out for
critics and audiences seems to be its
emphasis on family and Community wanted
to use a wrote the amount of times I
cried during this movie caught me off
guard but it hits all the right
emotional strings to me and the way the
cast portrayed the Latino family
Dynamics so perfectly another Twitter
user wrote not only is it a fantastic
introduction to Jaime Reyes as a
character slash hero but also a love
letter to the Latino culture that
focuses on family as its foundation
meanwhile one fan tweeted was expecting
this to be another generic superhero
flick but this movie pleasantly
surprised me with how good it was it's a
lot like Guardians of the Galaxy 2 with
this emphasis on family if this is what
the DCU will be like going forward then
it's definitely in good hands the film
is also a mining fans of 2008's Iron Man
enough's comparison considering that
Robert Downey Jr LED film launched a
billion dollar grossing Marvel Cinematic
Universe wanted the user wrote Blue
Beetle is pretty dumb great reminded me
of the original Iron Man in many ways
delivering a good old-fashioned origin
story that doesn't bug itself down with
greater Universe baggage I hope gun and
saffron stick to their word of haime
being the first DCU character audiences
have also been full of praise for the
castle Blue Beetle especially the lead
actor one fan tweeted cholo married
dueña was perfectly cast as Jaime Reyes
Blue Beetle and I'm so damn happy that
his story isn't even close to being over
and we're going to see his return
immediately in the DCU another Twitter
user agreed right saying Shirley Murray
duenya is perfectly cast and shines as
Jaime Reyes George Lopez and Bruno
marchesina are also standouts based on
the early reactions it looks like Blue
Beetle is a critical win that DC needs
after Black Adam Shazam Fury of the Gods
and this summers The Flash will Blue
Beetle be a box office head for DC while
initial projections are low it's
possible that positive word of mouth
could compel audiences to check out
Jaime reyes's big screen debut as the
first hero in the new DCU Blue Beetle is
in theaters now
[Music]
thank you